thank you trace sandra lindsay a
registered nurse in new york made
history yesterday
becoming the first person in the u.s to
get the vaccine
just over 24 hours ago you'll remember
this moment happened live
during our program yesterday lindsay's a
health care worker at the long island
jewish medical center and she is
featured
on the cover of the new york post this
morning nurse sandra lindsay joins us
now
good morning to you thanks so much for
joining us sandra and how did it feel to
to be the the headline and the key photo
on the cover the new york post this
morning
thank you very much for having me it's
surreal
um but i'm happy to be representing
healthcare workers and nurses all across
the world
god bless you because i know that this
was this was part of you wanting to send
a message
that it's safe to get the vaccine why
was it so important for you to sit in
that chair
and be the first in the nation to get
that shot
because i know that their people have a
lot of
apprehension and fear about taking the
vaccine
and my message to them is not to be
afraid because the alternative
is far worse i've seen too much pain too
much suffering too many people
that passed away as a result of covid19
and so i i stand by the signs
i believe in signs i trust signs and
i don't trust covid19 so it was
important for me and especially
you know to send the message to the
minority community
hispanic latinos blacks who are usually
grossly affected but still have mistrust
based on history sandra part of the
public fear
is that this will hurt that you'll get
sick from the shot
develop symptoms like covid how are you
feeling
this morning after receiving the first
dose i am feeling great
my temperature this morning was 98.1
no muscle weakness no muscle pain
arm soreness on a scale of one to ten
it's a one i i feel great
wow it's really something to hear you
say that and so important for all of us
uh to hear you say that so you await the
second
dose how much do you believe this will
eventually change
our way of life considering you've been
on the front lines you've
seen how bad and how evil this virus can
be
so my hope is that you know more people
will take the vaccine
because it doesn't help if a large
population of people don't take the
vaccine
and that will we'll see less suffering
less pain less deaths and
only when we get when the science
dictates that
we should take our mask off and stop
practicing social distancing
that's when we should stop but we should
continue
the fight the finish line is near the
light is
is brighter at the end of the tunnel but
we have to do our part and we need to
band together
to put this pandemic to rest once and
for all that light at the end of the
tunnel
is so important i just want to put this
up real quick before i let you go this
is your brother garfield lindsay
so proud of my younger sis for stepping
up and taking the covid19 vaccine like a
champ
she's witnessed firsthand too many
deaths and is leading by example by
doing what's necessary to beat this
virus
first in the u.s he writes i think so
so proud fair of all of us to say
thanks for doing it and thanks for
sitting in that chair taking the first
vaccine and sending
your message of hope to us this morning
thank you